New York City the afternoon of January
the 7th 2020 breaking news about two
dozen ballistic missiles hit United
States facilities in Iraq
more specifically the targets were
military bases in western Iraq where
hundreds of American soldiers are
deployed
this was the escalation of the latest
tension between Iran and the United
States that had erupted on January the
third on that day the US Army launched a
deadly strike against a convoy that was
leaving Baghdad Airport
traveling in that convoy were two
leading figures of Middle Eastern
geopolitics
the first was Kassim soleimani the
commander of the Kurds force special
operations group within the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard he was one of the
most important leaders of the Iranian
theocracy next to him was a be Marty
Almohad Asst chief of the Kataeb
Hezbollah or Hezbollah brigades Iraqi
militia founded in 2003 in order to find
US troops deployed in the country
[Music]
according to the Pentagon this deadly
strike was carried out according to
orders given by Donald Trump himself the
President of the United States now the
question is who was Kasim soleimani
what does the boss mean to Middle
Eastern politics why did Trump decide to
end his life why and how is Iran
reacting to this and the most important
question of all what happened next
are we about to witness a war between
the United States and Iran well let's
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all Salamone was not a random
person but one of the main characters in
Iranian politics from the perspective of
the West we could say he is the Joker
the Darth Vader and the hands Lander of
international politics
[Music]
yes dear viewer Kasim soleimani was the
most important military leader in Iran
and perhaps the second most powerful
leader in the country only surpassed by
the supreme leader Ayatollah Khamenei
Eve
[Music]
as we've discussed before here on visual
politic Iran is one of the us's arch
enemies so you can imagine the magnitude
of this man
[Music]
but in order to understand who mr.
Salamone really was we have to
understand health the Iranian army
actually works unlike most countries
Iran doesn't have one army but two yep
two different armies that work
completely independently of each other
[Music]
on the one hand we have a regular army
that has more than 350,000 soldiers
according to Article 143 of the Iranian
Constitution this army has the classic
tasks every Army has protecting the land
the borders securing infrastructure and
so on
[Music]
but then we have this other army the
so-called Islamic Revolutionary Guard of
this army was created in 1979 right
after the Revolution started by
Ayatollah Khomeini its main task is to
defend the ideological principles of the
revolution so why would they need such a
thing well think about it
after the Revolution Khomeini was afraid
of a coup d'etat rising from the
traditional army that had always been
loyal to the Shah of Persia prior to the
revolution so in order to quash any
would-be coup he created his own guard
but if you thought this was just a small
troop of elite bodyguards protecting
religious leaders why you better think
again the Islamic Revolutionary Guard
has around 150,000 troops and they have
far superior training and weaponry than
the Regular Army
but hold on for just a second because
that isn't all these troops don't answer
to the government that are under the
exclusive command of the Supreme Leader
in other words Hassan rouhani's the
Iranian president has no power over them
only the ayatollah khamenei ii does
having said that within this islamic
revolution regards there is another core
with greater autonomy and those are the
cuts force the Qods forces similar to a
cross between the CIA and Special Forces
in the United States
this means that they are elite troops
and an Intelligence Agency at the same
time they carry out all foreign
operations in other words the best
trained soldiers and the smartest spies
from throughout Iran belonged to this
group because force in charge of
expanding Iran's influence abroad and
these weather troops led by mr. Salamone
this is why we say that this man was the
architect of Iran's sphere of influence
in the Middle East and lately Iran has
been gaining a huge sway on the region
over time this man came to be in charge
of all Iranian regional policy that to
this his intelligence network and his
closeness to the supreme leader you can
understand why Salamone was far more
important to Iranian politics than the
President himself
want to see an example of this well what
do you think company calls him general
commander-in-chief no his official title
translates to living martyr of the
revolution and the truth is when it
comes to expanding Iran's influence and
causing problems for American troops
salah barney knew his stuff just have a
look at how some high-ranking men in
washington describe him for two decades
sulemani has been the most powerful
savvy and effective terrorists on the
planet he's enjoyed full backing of a
powerful terrorist state he is
irreplaceable mark dooba wits chief
executive of the foundation for the
defense of democracies as the cuts force
leader Salamone created a multinational
network that has become a headache for
both the u.s. and israel
after the Iraq invasion of 2003 the
helps force trains and gave weapons to
militias that US targets for example
they train small militias in the use of
sophisticated explosives that perforate
the shields of the armored vehicles used
by US troops these kinds of explosives
caused hundreds of US soldiers to lose
their lives those militias now have
thousands of troops who are fighting for
total control of Iraq
and the same goes for Afghanistan their
Iranian troops gave training weapons and
even direct support to the Taliban so
that they could fight the international
forces that were led by the United
States but if you're not impressed by
mr. Salloum Annie's track record hold on
a second because there's more in 2006
his support to Hezbollah a pro Iranian
terrorist group in Lebanon brought about
to the first retreat of the Israeli army
later on in Syria his support to the
al-assad regime was crucial for enabling
the dictator to keep his power but it
doesn't end there
in Yemen pro-iranian militias have
managed to hold their own against the
almighty saudi army the same goes for
the Gaza Strip where the Cubs force is
playing a key role in helping Hamas
still not surprised well look at
operations like this one September 14
2019 two major Saudi oil installations
hit by a drone strike u.s. blames Iran
New York Times July 20th 2019 Iran
seizes British tanker in Strait of
Hormuz BBC in a nutshell Salim Annie's
loss has been a huge blow to the
ayatollah regime
the American drone not only killed a key
Iranian figure it also brought massive
humiliation to the whole regime because
let's be honest here if the US drone can
take out the leader of your best elite
troop a lot of people are gonna stop
being afraid of Iran it is impossible to
overstate the importance of this
particular action it is more significant
that the killing of Osama bin Laden or
even the death of Islamic state leader
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi general david
petraeus former commander of u.s. armed
forces in iraq and afghanistan and a
former CIA director so okay I know
you're probably now thinking and that's
that well this is a great achievement
for the u.s. right well yeah and in a
way that's correct but on the other hand
it also comes with a huge risk killing
this man would not come without
retaliation this brings us to the next
question
why did Trump decide to carry out the
attack why did he want to unleash such a
political and diplomatic crisis at this
point in time well let's take a closer
look last night at my direction the
United States military successfully
executed a flawless precision strike
that killed the number one terrorist
anywhere in the world Qasem Soleimani
the keys behind Trump's decision oh
let's be clear here Washington always
hated this guy and wanted to kill him no
matter if we talked about Trump Obama or
even Bush
all of them have Soleimani on their hit
lists but until now nobody has wanted to
risk so much for him so then why did
Trump want this I know what you might be
thinking you might be thinking well it's
just good old Donald doing his thing
Trump just got crazy and basically said
whatever let's go and kill him
[Music]
that's actually not what happens in fact
there are three reasons that explain why
Trump acted the first one is the Iraq
situation Iraq has never been stable but
now it's getting even worse for several
months there has been a massive fight
between pro-iranian and anti-iranian
supporters so Iran is pushing their
effort to control the region this is why
the militias trained in Iran have been
harassing any opposing forces including
US troops they just want every US
soldier to leave the country this
explains the many attacks on US military
bases and the attempted assault of the
US Embassy thousands of protesters
attacked the American Embassy in Baghdad
shouting death to USA al mundo
[Applause]
it seems that Soleimani had gone to
Baghdad to coordinate massive attacks
against the US military presence there
and to take over the Iraqi political
institutions Salamone was plotting
imminent and sinister attacks on
American diplomats and military
personnel but we caught him in the act
and terminated him we took action last
night to stop a war we did not take
action to start a war
[Music]
but hold on a second because there is a
second reason and this is related to
this year 2020 the year of the u.s.
presidential elections and what would be
better for Trump than taking out one of
his arch enemies add to this the fact
that Trump needs to divert attention
from the impeachment process and his
lack of achievements on foreign policy a
victory in the Middle East would be a
godsend for his campaign and yet there's
also a third reason you see ever since
Trump came to the White House he has
increased pressure on Iran his goal is
to put the ayatollah regime against the
wall and hopefully spark a change of
regime
this explains breaking the nuclear deal
and the nuclear sanctions against the
country in a few moments I'll be signing
an executive order imposing hard-hitting
sanctions on the supreme leader of Iran
and the office of the Supreme Leader of
Iran and many others so far neither of
these works he's had to take a further
step besides with this operation the
United States scares off their opponents
because they flex their muscle in the
region but the question the real
question now is what's gonna happen next
are we really about to start a war with
the Middle East well let's see
[Music]
revenge
they're on his Swan they were retaliate
and we could say that the regime is in
shock Speer revenge awaits the criminals
who have stained their hands with his
and the other martyrs blood last night
marta Soleimani
is an international figure resistance
and all such people will seek revenge
Iranian supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei who's no doubt the great nation
of Iran and the other free nations of
the region will take revenge for this
gruesome crime from criminal America
Hassan rouhani president of Iran
the first retaliation was launching at
least two dozen ballistic missiles
against two US military bases our bill
and our sad now the question is does
this mean that the ayatollahs are
willing to start a war against the
United States of course we can't predict
what's in common is head but from a
strictly rational point of view it makes
absolutely no sense
revenge is one thing suicide is another
and we're not just talking about
military capability here think about it
anyone could predict that Iran would
avenge their dead general it was just a
fact the regime needed to respond to the
US strike the question is how the
Islamic Republic of Iran refuses to take
any emotional and hasty action we will
set up a plan patiently to respond to
this terrorist act in a crushing and
powerful manner we are the ones who set
the time and place of our reciprocal
response Brigadier General Abu Faisal
Shekar Qi a spokesman for the Iranian
armed forces sure they have sent more
than two dozen ballistic missiles and
set off alarm bells around the globe but
was it as big a deal as it seemed at the
time of making this video the Iranian
missiles had struck two second-tier US
facilities and no Americans have been
killed
this meant the Islamic Revolutionary
Guard chose two minor targets to save
face as a show of power inside Iran and
to create chaos within neighboring Iraq
at the same time they have reduced the
risk of counter retaliation from the
United States in other words they are
increasing the tension for a moment in
order to reduce it later on so does this
mean the escalation has stopped of
course not
especially not in Iran you see Iran is
famous for fighting without declaring
war they won't send uniformed men no
tanks or combat jets as you might expect
in a traditional war the ultimate
Iranian speciality is what we call
asymmetric warfare
this means informal attacks carried out
by groups that although supported by
Iran and not Iran in fact these kinds of
strategies were Salim Arnie's speciality
this is some things that the ayatollah
regime has been doing forever for
example in 1983 hezbollah bombed a
marine corps quarter in lebanon causing
more than 200 deaths the same happens
when Hezbollah attacked the Israeli
embassy in Buenos Aires since the
biggest Jewish Center in Argentina in
[Music]
we don't even have to go that far back
in time the Iraqi militias that have
been fighting US soldiers in Iraq caused
more than 600 deaths
that's not even mention Afghanistan
during 2019 pro-iranian groups hit a US
drone and harassed oil tankers in the
Strait of Hormuz also the Houthi rebels
attacked two of the most important Saudi
oil facilities this is straight from the
playbook of the cuts force and we can
expect more of this in the future it's a
huge threat the fact that we have f-16s
and f-35s is not relevant to this
problem retired Brigadier General Yossi
Cooper wasser former chief of the
research division at the Israeli Defense
Forces military intelligence branch and
it is hard to imagine a different
scenario even if the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard did dare to launch
these ballistic missiles basically they
couldn't do anything else because they
have no better weapons for it here are
some examples the most powerful tank
Iran has is the Russian t-72 that
started operating in the 1970s and this
is the most powerful because they still
use tanks from Vietnam or even the
Korean War the air fleet is even older
of course it all depends on what the
United States does but the truth is the
US wouldn't be interested in invading
Iran either we're talking about a huge
country with hundreds of thousands of
soldiers ready for battle and a high-end
anti-air system despite the fact they
only have short-range and medium-range
missiles and therefore couldn't attack
US soil they could cause significant
damage to US allies like Israel Saudi
Arabia or the United Arab Emirates
so unless there is a big surprise all we
can expect is a lot of tension and a lot
of asymmetric warfare but now it's your
turn what do you think is gonna happen
do you think despite all of our
reasoning there will be a war between
the United States and Iran or please
leave your answer in the comment section
below also don't forget to check out
reconsider Mediacom the podcast that
provided the voices in this episode that
were not mine also we publish brand new
videos every week so please do subscribe
to this channel and hit that Bell button
so you won't miss any posts and if you
like this video please do give us a
thumbs up and as always see you next
time and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
Media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]